après 25 ans de carrière à nos côtés
c'est aujourd'hui que le journaliste
culturel de radio canada claude eychenne
tire sa révérence on ne met pas fin à 25
ans de présence quotidienne au
téléjournal sans une certaine mélancolie
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il a écrit dans
une lettre qu'il a publié hier est à mes
côtés bonjour claude pour jeu peut se
mettre cinq ans mais c'est surtout
trente trois ans parce qu'il ya aussi
huit ans qui ont été passés à toronto
exactement mais années fondatrices ah
oui c'est ça brille ça passe tellement
vite 33 ans et c'est ça vous permet de
faire le bilan du travail que vous avez
accompli c'est beaucoup de travail 30 3
c mais ça paraît pas à 50
oui ça passe incroyable mais vrai c'est
que quand on fait un travail comme ça au
quotidien un sujet chasse l'autre on est
là vous en savez quelque chose où ils
étaient tous les jours
en fait un sujet et on oublie le sujet
du tour est comme ça au bout du compte
on se rend compte que ça fait 25 ans on
a l'impression un moment donné de faire
partie des meubles que les gens ne
remarquent pas et depuis j'ai annoncé
mon départ en mars dernier je me rends
compte à quel point ce que j'ai fait a
été reçue par les gens je ne soupçonnais
pas ça c'est vraiment curieux vous êtes
aussi dans votre lettre que vous voulez
remercier tous ceux qui vous hante à
campagne c'est important les collègues
de travail pour l'équipe je suis rien
sans l'équipe il ya mon caméraman didier
qui nous suit aujourd'hui mais c'est
déjà l'affecta trice de louise rousseau
l'élément tard
les journalistes avec moi les assistants
tous ces gens que des gens voient
regarder la télé derrière nous sans là
pour nous appuyer
est il en panne à renens lisant pas la
face et moi je suis là avec mon sujet
pour essayer d'être à la hauteur du
travail qui donne et federer oui c'est
ça et je récolte aujourd'hui de plein de
bons messages mais c'est grâce aussi à
tous ceux qui pensent à suivre mais si
vous avez été témoin de la montée de
nombreux artistes qualité qu'elle a été
celui qui vous a le plus marqué ce but
vous avez vu évoluer en étant tout à
fait surpris et content pour lui il
faudrait probablement pas remonter à
très loin pour pouvoir vous pouvoir
une évolution incroyable choisi stéphane
rousseau je me rappelle la première fois
je l'avais vu juste un petit coeur qui
les élit bas avec roméo pérusse
regardons ce que stéphane rousseau est
devenu aujourd'hui mais ariane moffatt à
l'époque où elle faisait partie du
groupe très jeune je me suis dit cette
fille là va aller loin
regardez ce qu'elle est devenue c'est
formidable et j'ai toujours aimé dans ma
carrière pouvoir justement identifier
des gens qui quittent valait la peine
d'être suivi un premier reportage pour
la cuisine âge marche pas parce que je
chante des noms qui avaient été bien vu
c'est céline dion la première fois je
l'interviewais ces tests et de papillons
qui avait laissé sa robe de première
communiante d'un garde robe avec ses
longues jambes et j'ai suivi son
évolution jusqu'à ce qu'elle est je fais
ce qu'elle devienne là c'était l'armée
avec henri salvador a séduit je te colle
à ses débuts une enceinte et j'ai été
chanceux j'ai rencontré henri salvador
j'ai rencontré les gens paient le rythme
jean-paul-riopelle c'est un privilège
d'être la personne qui est choisi par
ado canada pourrait aller raconter ces
gens-là et sert de lien avec le public
parce que le public est tout aussi
important on fait ça pour eux il ya t'il
des entrevues qui vous ont surpris c'est
à dire des commentaires qui ont été
faits des gens que vous avez redécouvert
comme je sais ça d'imaginer un artiste
qui vous a vraiment marqué vous avez dit
je l'imaginais peut-être pas comme ça
que c'est vraiment une personne
sympathique ou rups c'est surprenant
l'atuge aurait pas de jeu pas d'idées
qui me vienne en rit non pour être franc
je ne sais pas faudrait que j'y
réfléchirai
dans le domaine culturel et bien sûr y'a
la chanson à l'opéra et à la danse
qu'est ce qui vous plaît le plus
ben j'ai beaucoup aimé parler de musique
parce que dans un reportage de deux
minutes
la musique ça c'est sûr que ça soutient
bien deviné le cinéma c'est formidable
aussi parce que c'est un art grand
public et les gens s'identifient à une
activité qui va leur permettre de sortir
pour pas trop cher
la chanson c'est peut-être mon genre
préféré la chanson francophone
particulièrement c'est un petit peu du
domaine culturel souvenirs communs que
j'ai avec vous et de partager de ces
cette vidéo en septembre on a été
ensemble pendant que vous étiez là pour
le printemps du québec québec je ne sais
trop
et puis et donc on avait échangé
ensemble nous décrivions je suis j'ai
parlé de mon taxi je me souviens bien je
te donne des joueurs avec les syriens et
la nouvelle que vous venez de lire quand
samuel 2001 qu'elle fasse de la semaine
avant il y avait vu cette même nouvelle
cette même alerte au terrorisme
j'avais entendu chaud pendant que je me
préparais à découvrir michael jackson
parce que c'était la raison pour
laquelle j'étais et je me suis retrouvé
dans un événement qui était un événement
déterminant dans l'histoire
contemporaine qui a changé le monde en
face à vichy qui maman qui m'a servi
personnellement c'est plate à dire que
une tragédie comme celle-là puisse nous
aider parce que ça m'a donné confiance
parce que j'ai pu répondre à la commande
comment donner ce matin-là mois de
journalistes culturels
il va nous parler de ce qui se passe en
tout cas ça nous permet de vous rassurer
peut-être que vous vous êtes dit aussi
je ne suis pas que j'en ai les
sculptures est je suis un journaliste
mais on est journaliste
oui mais quand en face du culturel du
sport d'économie on est tous des
journalistes parce que quand on
travaille dans cette boîte là on a tous
les mêmes exigences de rigueur de
contenu oui ça fait maintenant c'est
l'heure de la retraite
oui les projets des projets quelques
joints par exemple je parlais de ma
carrière dans des conférences que je
donne et dans le cadre des journées de
la culture j'étais invitée à faire ça
s'amusant partager ses expériences
je m'en vais encore et vous si j'étais
invité par monsieur une beigne de
l'organisme québec corrie vais-je aller
voir sur ce président là donc j'invite à
deux festivals jong joo puis assez haut
lieu au mois d'octobre
c'est une offre incroyable maintenant
que je ne suis plus soumis aux pratiques
et aux guides des pratiques
journalistiques je peux accepter les
voyages payés quand on a couvert autant
la culture à ce que c'est parce qu'on
est soi-même un artiste à sable non non
non je ne me suis pas un artiste non non
je n'ai jamais été wanna be moi j'aime
mon métier mon talent
mon expérience c'est de faire le passage
entre ceux qui créent et le public c'est
là que ma créativité s'exprime un métier
qui a évolué j'ai commencé en film et
puis maintenant je tweete pendant les
entractes des spectacles imaginés
l'évolution que ça représente
alors s'est il faut s'adapter c'était
une adaptation après l'autre chaque
nouveauté à amener quelque chose
d'intéressant mais ça enlève aussi des
choses
tweet à 140 caractères et les gens
pensent que c'est ça mais des nuances
s'exprime quand on parle d'un spectacle
ou d'une oeuvre d'art
ça prend des nuances quand c'est bon
quand c'est pas bon ça il faut le dire
quand les choses sont bonnes ou pas
bonne ainsi bien que vous souhaiteriez
exprimé là pour l'avenir du métier parce
que vous avez dit tu es content d'eux
n'est peut-être pas cette place au
culturel me colle un moment donné ne pas
oublier que c'est important c'est celle
qui nous fait la culture au québec on
francophones du canada parce qu'on pense
à lisser le blanc radio radio ici au
québec et englobe toute cette vitalité
culturelle
c'est important qu'on représente sûr
parce que c'est une force qu'on a et
c'est aussi important que que le
canadien que le cs la cs l'accueil de la
bombarde il à ses séries oui c'est du
même niveau
si non plus parce que ça va chercher des
gens dans leur slip
j'y reviens vous personnellement c'est
difficile de se voir vieillir à l'écran
oui alors on est toujours plus beau
quand on est jeune ça me paraissait
toujours aussi jeune surprenante vous
entendre dire que vous partez à la
retraite merci que les autres pour ses
25 ans
j'avais beaucoup 60
laisse le mot de la fin voilà là c'est
foutu
merci qu'un au revoir